so here we have iodine it's um it's a
halogen but it's quite low in the group
of the halogen so unlike fluorine and
chlorine and bromine it's it's not a
liquid or a gas it's actually a solid
okay but it's a very very volatile solid
just like some of the materials further
on in the group so here if we take some
out we see it's a really quite lovely
material iodine is an element which many
people have seen because it's used in
solution a sort of violet colored
solution for treating cuts and grazes
because it has strong antiseptic
properties it's actually purple but the
light doesn't really do it justice so
you can see it looks like a dark grey as
it gets warm unless you start to
evaporate and sublime I didn't is an
element that is essential to life if you
don't have iodine you do not develop
properly it's important for the thyroid
function the thyroid is a small gland in
your neck and in this area of the UK
which is far away from the sea people in
the old days suffered from a deficiency
of iodine which made their thyroid gland
grow very large and so they got a
disease called guita
which in this area was known as
Derbyshire neck and nowadays iodine is
added to table salt and so that there
are very few people in the UK that have
adding deficiency so here iodine has
lots and lots of different applications
it's used for purification of water so
if you got water within it with a
waterborne problem like about some
bacteria just a couple of crystals of
iodine and that really really
neutralizes them and then it makes the
water really quite much safer but you
can see that it's starting to leave some
stains on the paper and this is simply
because we're all donating the paper
itself so I told you earlier under this
it's it's quite volatile so what we're
going to do is we're going to take the
ideal across and we're going to put it
into the beaker and warm it up slightly
from below for example if you take
tadpoles and small baby frogs
they will not turn into frogs unless you
and iodine to the water so if you bring
on tadpoles up in active conditions they
cannot develop so we put the iodine
crystals in and watch what happens again
rather like like like strontium that
raided that radioactive iodine was
formed by some nuclear reactions and so
one of the things that has happened
after serious nuclear incidents like in
Chernobyl or in the UK in 1957 in
Windscale that the children were given
iodine tablets to take to prevent their
bodies absorbing a radioactive iodine
from the environment purple crystals of
iodine now subliming and becoming more
volatile so that purple color is really
really good in it
top job